[Musique]
on commence les informations du jour par
cette tragédie survenue ce lundi en
Turquie et en Syrie un séisme d'une
magnitude 7,8 et des répliques ont
frappé ces deux pays au moins 5000
personnes sont mortes d'après les
dernières estimations dans les Yvelines
13 sapeurs-pompiers se rendent sur place
pour aider la population avec notamment
un médecin une infirmière et un chien de
recherche il rejoignent le détachement
USA spécialisés dans le sauvetage et le
déblament la solidarité s'organise
également dans le département le Secours
populaire des Yvelines débloque une
première somme de 5000 euros et lance un
appel au don pour pousser à la
solidarité au soutien financier pour les
victimes de la catastrophe sur le plan
national 100 000 euros de fond d'urgence
ont été débloqués pour les familles pour
donner les dons peuvent se faire en
ligne sur le site officiel du Secours
populaire
après les journées du 19 et 31 janvier
un nouveau mouvement de greffe contre la
réforme des retraites était organisée ce
mardi 7 février dans toute la France
selon les organisations syndicales à
mobilisation est toujours aussi forte 17
buts CGT sont partis aujourd'hui depuis
les Yvelines certains depuis trap une
mobilisation qui a eu des conséquences
sur les transports avec intrins sur deux
pour le RER A ou encore un train sur 3
pour le RER BC des chiffres similaires
pour les trains sur la ligne JLN et U du
côté de l'enseignement les chiffres sont
en baisse selon l'académie de Versailles
dans le premier degré on est passé de
41% de grévistes le 19 janvier à 11,43%
ce mardi 7 février au collège on recense
15,43 % d'enseignants en grève et 9,42
dans les lycées l'association
protectrice des animaux la SPA lance une
application éphémère pour trouver son
futur compagnon pendant la période de la
Saint-Valentin le concept une fois
l'application téléchargée 5 questions
seront posées à l'internaute pour mieux
le connaître ainsi
identifier l'animal qui lui correspond
le mieux le refuge le plus proche pour
rencontrer des pensionnaires lui sera
ainsi suggérés trois refuges sont
ouverts dans les Yvelines à Orgeval
Hermeray et à plaisir le Paris
Saint-Germain qui déménagera l'été
prochain son centre d'entraînement à
Poissy pour être également changer de
stats selon nos confrères de l'équipe le
PSG à mandaté en intermédiaire pour
l'aider à trouver un site pour la
construction d'un nouveau stade dans la
région il s'agirait de la société
Legends une entreprise qui a déjà
travaillé dans le football avec le Real
Madrid et Manchester City les
propriétaires Cateri voudraient toujours
un stade une capacité de 60 000
personnes il y a quelques jours le
député de la douzième circonscription
des Yvelines carloli avait suggéré de
construire un stade à Poissy mais si et
Neymar joueront-ils dans les Yvelines
réponse dans les prochaines semaines
[Musique]